Yeah,
mood, that's
right, huh
[Music] Hmm,
major,
me,
that child's flower collection, I learned a little about the rules of this tearful anus
, so shed tears in it.  It's soothing to have a stress-relieving effect
. It's
just a matter of shedding that tear in the old days. It's said that the relieving effect lasts for a week, so the
purpose of this time is
to communicate with other employees.  Since the purpose is to want people to communicate with each other for the first time,
there is no opportunity for employees to cry and show each other, so I will
go to the company and do it for many
periods, so I will try to get that feeling as much as possible.  Creating an environment and
when that feeling comes out It's only a short time to express that feeling, but I think I'd
like to
do that kind of difficulty
so that I can snuggle up to it.  There is no such thing, but
for example,
the emotions of women before and after receiving the program change in a very attractive way
.
It was so deep and it was so
embarrassing [Music] Well, I was a little embarrassed.
Yes, I was
so shy.
I gave you a relaxing loan I
wonder if it's cute
se Inami no Ko Who
says that Japan
doesn't show its emotions very much It takes some culture to put up with it.
Is possible.
Garbage emerges. If there are people who can't even unknowingly show their emotions,
it's the pond's
famous place. Aniran
ni
[Music]
Heal me.  I
swear that I shouldn't be an oppa duck in Japan, where I said that it would be okay if I had a nice woman come and try it,
but
if I could see a crying face, it would be again.  That makes me feel
more intimate. I think it's more than an activity, so
I spread roll cutlets all over the world.  I definitely want to keep going
Yes
, so I can't help but think of that cocotte face
Amun
[Music]